-As COVID cases continue
to climb,
GOP politicians are doubling
down on their opposition
to mask and vaccine mandates.
On top of everything else,
the FDA has to warn people
not to take livestock dewormer.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
-COVID cases
are continuing to rise
and public health officials
are pleading with people
to get vaccinated
and wear a mask.
And yet, last night,
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis,
whose state has been recording
more daily cases on average
in the last few weeks than
anytime during the pandemic,
and who is against mask
and vaccine mandates,
actually blamed
the Biden administration
for not ending COVID.
-He said he was gonna end COVID.
He hasn't done that.
-It's quite a feat to be
the biggest [bleep] in Florida
and not be from New York.
Normally, it's the retired
New Yorkers creating problems.
One time I was buying board
shorts at a surf shop in Boca
and I overheard a guy yelling at
a cashier,
"You telling me it's 8 bucks
for a puka shell necklace
when I could go down to the
beach and get 'em for free?
Get the [bleep] out of here."
That said, I think he ended up
buying the necklace.
-Yeah, that's right. I did.
That gonna be a problem?
-No, not gonna be a problem.
I'm making an observation.
-Okay. Good for you.
Now do your little show.
-Okay, I will.
[ Laughter ]
Shoemaker, will you walk me
to my car tonight?
DeSantis really knows
how to boil your blood,
which is a bummer, because
Florida usually conjures up
feelings of vacation
and relaxation,
or the very least, you know,
gators on meth benders.
Their governor should be one of
those old guys
who grows a ponytail
to make up for going bald
and has a platinum membership
at Tommy Bahama,
but somehow they ended up with
this comic book henchman.
Whenever this guy
says something,
it just brings out
the New Yorker in me.
I have the same reaction
to DeSantis that I do
when I see a guy
double-park his BMW
in a fire lane
outside a Duane Reade.
I'm just like,
"This [bleep] guy."
-I was just running in
for a Monster Energy.
That's a problem?
-What?
-I was double-parked
because I was running in
for a Monster Energy.
Is that a problem?
-No, that's your right
as an American.
[Quietly] Seriously, maybe bring
your pepper spray, too.
Anyway, back to Ron DeSantis.
You're blaming the federal
government for not ending COVID
when your state just passed
3 million cases,
ICU's are filling up,
hospitals are fighting
to get oxygen.
Instead of promoting mitigation
efforts we know can work,
like masks, you've actively
stood in the way of mandates --
even in schools.
You can't just make us
forget about all that.
Those facts
are all public record.
They don't just disappear
like sweet nothings
whispered in the summer wind.
And, by the way,
those don't disappear either.
"You said you'd love me
till the end of time!"
"Well, I didn't know
you were gonna
put wet towels on the bed!"
That's why Fox News exists,
to create an upside-down world
where nothing matters.
Not only do they exist
in a reality-free bubble,
but they don't even adhere
to their own internal logic.
One day, for example, when
they're pushing back
against efforts to get
more people vaccinated,
an anchor like Brian Kilmeade
will say something like this.
-I don't think anchors should be
recommending medical advice.
-Yeah. I agree.
-Well, you know, but a lot of
people have been tuning in
to the show for 25 years
to see what we think
about different things.
I think if you have the
opportunity, get the shot.
-Right, but shouldn't you see
a doctor to give you expertise
about what they're seeing?
-You're a doctor, and that's
what people usually do --
they call their doctor
for medical advice.
And that's what
people should be doing.
Dr. Siegel, thanks so much.
-Right, don't call
the president -- call me.
You got it.
-Yeah, or anchors.
We should just talk to doctors.
-I'm surprised Kilmeade is so
bullish on consulting doctors,
especially after
the way they botched
his eye-closening surgery.
And they reveal themselves
as wealthy and out of touch
when they say something like,
"Call your doctor."
This is America --
lots of people,
especially young and low-income
people, don't have doctors.
You might as well say,
"If you want more information
on this story,
talk to the head butler
on your yacht."
Second, anchors, including
your co-host Steve Doocy --
and credit to him --
they aren't recommending
medical advice by telling you
about a lifesaving vaccine
during a deadly pandemic
any more than "Hot Ones"
is recommending dietary advice
by telling you to drink milk
with your wings.
Which -- side note -- might help
with your mouth,
but it's an awful combination
for your stomach.
I won't go into details, but
two days after I did that show,
I was on WebMD
typing in the words,
"What do you do if you can't
stop [bleep] your pants?"
Let's see.
"Take off your pants"?
Well, that's not the help
I was hoping for.
[ Laughter ]
And also -- side note --
there's a lot of cursing
in today's "A Closer Look,"
and that's because last night,
the Mets lost 3-2
to the Giants and dropped
to four games below .500.
They hit into five double plays.
When I came in this morning,
our security guard Jim Breyer
was fully sobbing.
And he thought he was dying
because he had never
cried before.
He didn't know what tears were.
He told me he didn't even go
home yesterday after the show.
He just rode the Long Island
Railroad all night
drinking Natty Light tallboys.
Apparently, they run a special
train just for that
after the Mets lose,
and that train is now the
leading cause of global warming.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway, the point is,
that's what Fox
and other right-wing figures
have often said
when the topic
of vaccines come up --
don't listen to anchors or
politicians for medical advice.
But then when they wanted
to promote
Regeneron's monoclonal antibody
treatment for COVID patients,
they had a slightly
different take.
-If you don't get vaccinated
and you go to the hospital,
most of the time,
you're going to get Regeneron.
But Regeneron are
the antibodies,
so you're basically still
getting vaccinated be
'cause they're sticking you
with an antibody.
-No, it's not the same
as getting vaccinated,
any more than getting
defibrillated is the same thing
as taking your heart medication.
Now, there's definitely evidence
that monoclonal antibodies
can be effective, especially in
reducing severe disease,
and that is great.
But public officials have
stressed it's not a cure
and it's not the way
out of the pandemic.
As with any illness, it's much
better to prevent people
from getting sick
in the first place.
So telling people it's the same
as getting vaccinated
is deeply irresponsible, because
while Regeneron may work
as a treatment,
safe and effective vaccines
that provide
tremendous protection
against severe disease and death
are abundant
and they're easy to get.
You can walk into pharmacies,
health centers, mobile clinics,
or megasites and get a shot
in like 20 minutes and be done.
Restaurants are offering them
with appetizers now.
The other day,
I went to a dinner party,
and we ordered a round
of Pfizer shots for the table
along with crab pfupfs
and chicken pfingers.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, this has been
the case on the right
since the start of the pandemic.
For some reason when it comes to
vaccines, they say things like,
"Don't listen to anchors
and politicians --
talk to your doctor."
But then they have
a very different take
when it comes to unproven
treatments
like the antimalaria drug
hydroxychloroquine,
or most recently
something called ivermectin.
-We know that our FDA has
in many ways failed us
by not allowing for the use
of ivermectin
and hydroxychloroquine,
both of which are used
around the world
to reduce COVID hospitalizations
and deaths.
-They seem to keep saying
vaccination is the only answer,
the only answer.
And we now know from studies
and also from the evidence
that we saw of the use of
ivermectin in India
that it does work.
-I don't know how many --
100,000 lives
might have been saved
if they had let the public
and doctors talk about
hydroxychloroquine and
ivermectin and prescribe it
without being called
by a pharmacist
as if they are doing
something illegal.
-This drug, ivermectin,
has been called,
at least by some doctors,
a miracle drug
when it comes
to treating COVID-19.
There's a good chance everyone
listening at home
has never heard of ivermectin
because Google has gone about
censoring any discussions,
including discussions inside the
halls of Congress
about this drug
from their platforms,
including YouTube.
-My God, Fox News has
basically turned into
one of those spam emails
promising you
free natural boner pills
for life.
Anytime someone tries
to sell you a miracle drug
that "they" don't want
you to know about,
you should be suspicious.
That's how I end up with a case
of Mike Lindell's My Pills.
They were supposed to help me
grow a full, luxuriant mustache,
but I only ended up
with one or two of
[Chicago accent] da hairs!
[Normal voice]
So, what exactly is ivermectin?
-This is a deworming agent,
a parasitic deworming agent
for livestock
that has been used for years
and around the world.
What is it chemically?
-Yeah, so, you're talking about
an anti-infective
that has been used
for a number of conditions --
everything from skin conditions
to parasitic conditions.
But again, this is
pharmaceutical grade,
not livestock grade
that's being prescribed.
And we really are starting
to get these kind of crazy calls
where people are now
playing doctor,
and this is very dangerous.
-The Mississippi State
Department of Health
confirming today that "at least
70% of the recent calls
to poison control in Mississippi
have been related to ingestion
of livestock or animal
formulations of ivermectin
purchased at
livestock supply centers."
-I mean, you wouldn't
get your --
treat your pneumonia with
your animal's medication.
It can be dangerous to get the
wrong doses of medication,
especially for something that's
meant for a horse or a cow.
-I got to say,
when I first heard
that Fox News
was pushing ivermectin,
I knew it was gonna be bad,
but I was not expecting it
to be horse dewormer.
Sounds like the name of a drug
they give super soldiers
in a Paul Verhoeven movie
to turn them into Robocops.
You know someone at the company
that made ivermectin once said,
"Hey, should we put
'not for people'
on the horse pill labels?"
and someone else said,
"There's a picture of a horse
on the bottle!
It's fine!"
I mean, how does this [bleep]
keep getting dumber and dumber?
First it was hydroxychloroquine,
then it was bleach,
powerful lights,
now it's horse dewormer.
I'm honestly terrified
to imagine what's next.
One day we're going to wake up
and Brian Kilmeade is going to
be telling people you can cure
COVID by eating kibble
and sleeping
in a bed of kitty litter.
"Works for me! That's why
I blink as often as a sphinx."
Normally when you hear the
phrase "horse pills,"
you think it's a euphemism,
but in this case,
it's literal horse pills.
Imagine getting that offer
in the bathroom at a club.
"Hey, man, you want
to ride the stallion?"
"Sure. What is it?"
"Heart pills for a stallion."
Things have gotten so bad,
the WHO and Merck
have warned against
using ivermectin.
And this week, the FDA had to
issue a tweet saying
"You are not a horse.
You are not a cow.
Seriously, y'all. Stop it."
There is no better indicator
of where we're at as a nation
that the face of the FDA
has resorted to "y'all."
The juxtaposition of
anti-vaccine rhetoric
and scam artists pushing
an unproven livestock dewormer,
is just so crazy.
In Texas, for example,
the governor just banned
vaccine mandates
even though the Pfizer vaccine
is now fully approved.
At the same time, calls to Texas
poison control about ivermectin
are soaring.
There's been a 550% increase.
On top of everything else now,
doctors have to deal
with this [bleep] too.
Can you imagine
how exhausted they are?
"Doc, I'm feeling a little" --
"Did you take horse pills?"
"No, no, I didn't!
Sorry, I gotta sneeze."
[ Nickers ]
[ Laughter ]
"I did take horse pills."
I mean, if you think
doctors are fed up,
imagine how employees
at feed stores feel.
Here's a report from local store
in Georgia
where a reporter had to call
local feed stores to ask them
about customers trying to buy
ivermectin for COVID.
-Some folks are lining up for
the FDA-approved Pfizer vaccine.
Others are trying a different
approach to fight COVID-19 --
animal dewormer.
-Never thought I'd have to do
an explainer
on why people should not use
animal dewormer,
but here we are.
Several feed stores
in central Georgia say
they're sold out of the drug
called ivermectin.
One employee at the
Tractor Supply in Byron told me
they can't keep it on the
shelves over the last few days.
I called over a dozen stores
until I found a small
mom-and-pop feed store.
When I asked the employee if
they had it in stock,
he said yes,
but he asked, "Are you buying
this for an animal?
Ma'am, please don't say
you're buying this for COVID."
That's where we are right now.
-You know who the real victims
are here?
The horses who can't get
their worm pills.
Whoa, Smokey. Whoa.
I got bad news, boy.
I been to every feed store in
the state, but they're all out.
I did get you a Pfizer vaccine.
they were about to throw away
because it was gonna expire.
Easy, boy!
Easy, Smokey.
[ Laughter ]
We have a political coalition
fighting against mask
and vaccine mandates
while also pushing
unproven miracle cures.
This just proves yet again
that you shouldn't get
medical information
from right-wing media any more
than you should get it from --
-A horse or a cow.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe, wear a mask,
get vaccinated.
We love you.